très pas que sur la compilation de jeux
un peu là je dirais même de jeux
gratuits lucas hochart et oui et on
commence avec un jeu incroyable qui
s'appelle ce jeu avec des explosions et
des slow motion c'est vraiment le temps
de jeu ça a été fait par les mecs qui
ont fait au total est accusé de battles
simulateur et reuters trucks et salaires
extrêmement cool le but est très simple
ya un pavillon en train d'exploser au
ralenti en slow motion voilà comme ça et
il faut pénétrer dedans et mourir il
faut sauter sur les cailloux voilà pour
pénétrer dans le bâtiment et trouver le
chat lui même c'est qu'on sait pas où
est le char à l escalade escalade
escalade escalade
il est où dan est un humain on s'en bat
les couilles c'est le chat qu'on veut
sauver paix aux animaux attend le bus
les est en train d'exploser salma il
faut que je me dépêche
je parie que le shérif tout au moins
clairement mais qu'est ce qu'ils font
[ __ ] les mecs sont morts brésil et
seront mais on n'est pas des on n'est
pas des brigands mec [ __ ] mais attend
il va mourir le mec là où je l'envoyer à
l'émeute
il est sur le toit le chat il est là et
alors c'est quoi ça ah c'est tout ce que
je viens de faire en sens inverse
il y acquiert le veulent mais n'y a pas
qu'un le bal mais c'est le jeu le plus
stylé de la vidéo faut pas quelqu'un
level bell viseo tombe à l'eau assiège
et moi c'est le même il même qu'exposant
fait d'accord ok on y va on va essayer
de la faire en mode en passant sur les
sur les morceaux de ciment c'est
beaucoup plus stylé oh là là oh la la
voilà ça fait tellement super héros
comme ça mec
[Musique]
hop là on passe on va s'en aller sur ce
caillou dalle est ce pas facile d'être
en coque mon gars me connaissez hancock
ado je pars pas de banc le coach papa
thaïlande à ok le caillou qu'est l'art
va s'appuyer dessus et nous fait monter
à l'étagé supérieur qui nous permet il
ya plus de mecs [ __ ] merde c'est
aléatoire en fait vite il me faut des
débris s'il vous plaît des débris comme
nos agendas pour construire ton petit
kevlar pour pas de faire un one shot au
haut non je n'ai pas sauvé donc j'ai
perdu 2,8 à temps mais c'est pas facile
ce jeu aussi là c'est en fait je peux
mourir j'ai besoin je suis enfin si mais
pas du tout à fait de l'explosion
remonte petit à petit un même si on
dirait pas aux places à poubelles jetées
dans l'explosion que le pire
sapeurs-pompiers du groupe auquel aia
qui vient par là ça dégage
je suis désolé je les sentais en péril
de ma vie
[Musique]
m
j'imaginais plus une médication du chien
mais pourquoi pas il ya une question qui
trotte dans ma tête
elle est même au galop si tu vois ce que
je veux dire être vous un vrai geek un
vrai nerd parce que quand on dit non
c'est un coup c'est plus stylée que geek
alors j'entends des ouïes par lala pas
trop bon écoute est avec para one man
show devant un public qui n'existe pas
génial ce troisième jeu s'intitule pc
building simulator pas de panique à bord
je vais traduire le titre parce qu'elle
durera traduire ça veut dire construire
un pc simulator voilà on a deux mille
dollars
on va faire un [ __ ] de pc gamer en
somme pour pas qu'on le fera gagner à la
fin de la vidéo
bah non pas dans la vraie vie je fais
gagner le pc du jeu j'enverrai ma
sauvegarde du jeu quoi monsieur on va
pas une carte graphique la asus gtx 590
le jeu a été fait hier ils sont dans les
680 aujourd'hui on est dans l'emile ces
types par la graphique yard
on va la [ __ ] du coup il n'y a même
pas de nom par nom il ya pas de carte
mère encore ah bah oui une carrière vie
ne peut pas un schiste il n'a pas de
carte mère carte mère c'est ce sur quoi
tu fous taram ton processeur ton truc
c'est ce qui relie tous mais j'explique
j'explique des amis et j'ai moi une fois
j'ai mis j'ai reçu j'ai acheté une carte
fille que j'aimais moyenne dans mon pc
ok j'ai dû me décharge an increase tests
adn l'ouvrir pour pas cramé mon pc fin
j'avais lu ça donc je me suis des
charges électricité alors motherboard je
suppose c'est ça motherboard mère
déborde
hop là on l'a mise attention ces
tutoriels n'est pas et factice ne
n'allait pas commander les composants
d'un pc pour construire et dans la vraie
vie en vous basant sur ce que je fais là
je veux pas être responsable des
milliers d'euros perdus une fois qu'on a
mis la carte mère on va mettre la asus
bien évidemment juste ici une fois que
la carte mère est mise les cartes
graphiques pardon graphique n'importe
quoi de la carte graphique est en place
on peut presque lancé bf en ultra mais
il faut aussi l'aide d'un processeur
voilà on s'est compris memory on met la
ram c'est ici alors là je me suis enfui
à pied sur ces petits trucs blanc pour
débloquer l'accès mettre la rame
hervé roues énormes ça se verrouille
tout seul raconte ouais voilà et envoie
gamme g ou d'un baiser je me sens frais
et frère hbp show démarre grâce à ça on
va rajouter une autre barre est non pas
de shit jeunes délinquants mais n'aura
bien sûr mais évidemment une fois que
c'est fait il va falloir mettre un
disque dur pour mettre un disque dur ça
se met ici ça c'est des ce lot de
disques durs alors on va le mettre juste
là disque dur physique ou alors ssd si
vous voulez que ce soit un petit peu
plus rapide à on est gourmand se met
bien cousins on en met plusieurs on n'a
pas les tunes c'est mort on n'a pas
l'étude on va ensuite mettre une
alimentation qui va bien sûr à alimenter
le buzz in 500 watts n'a en fait non
plus que 500 watts par mme séguin est
mort mais bon
amateurs les gens qu'on fait de jeu il
faut ensuite mettre un petit ventilateur
de manière à ventiler le tout ça se met
juste là c'est toujours ce truc là que
plein de poussière sur ton pc et wii
regarde regarde vas-y vas-y tu as le
temps mais pourquoi tu acheté un pc
portable aussi une fois que ça c'est
fait on va mettre un cpu cooler juste la
voilà qui permet bien sûr de rafraîchir
le procès puisque ça chauffe énormément
imposition bien évidemment tout comme
tous cas dans ce [ __ ] de pc et tu
devrais changer dans deux ans parce
qu'il aura tellement chauffé que ce sera
uzès comme les deux kadhafi a nommé deux
cartes graphiques on est gourmand voilà
on veut de la plus hausse sauf la sl il
comme on appelle ça et c'est libération
qui est l'abréviation de salma limitée
imbéciles pascal bassi ne double pas la
puissance de ton pc mais ça augmente de
20% dans les jeux voilà contrairement
aux idées reçues
eh ouais peut-être que les puristes vous
m'insultez parce que ces 22 % est pas
vain ou peut-être 30
je sais pas acheter ça me plaît guaino
alors on va mettre un ventilo ici aussi
pour le plaisir parce que nous amuse
bien sûr sachant que ton pc écolosol il
sert un peu rien ou bien on voyait même
pas compte il aussi mais enfin je crois
que j'ai encore une fois de les remettre
aux normes je viens pas de ventilo ici
[ __ ] y'a pas bon du tout interpol pâte
la pâte thermique qu'on a oublié bien
sûr donc le processeur va instante
cramer c'est pas grave on va ensuite
mettre la drève covers et ses petites
plaques que tu retires ton pc on a pu en
dessus voilà je viens d'ouvrir le mien
mais je peux pas vous la montrer elle
reste attachée au pc une fois que les
plaques sont mises on n'a pas d'acteur
cd abate déçu pourquoi t'es-tu théodore
parce que tu pourras pas dire le dvd
twilight que ton père t'a offert pour
ton anniversaire c'est triste c'est
comme ça tu iras ce qui rassure et bulle
parce qu'on est en 2002 dans cette vidéo
ensuite tu mets le side panel bien
évidemment bien sûr avec une petite vite
parce que tu veux que quand les gens
viennent chez toi il voit ta carte
graphique et état est ta mémoire ram
bien sûr les amis le pc totalement prêt
y'a plus qu'à l'envoyer à celui qui me
l'avait commandé et voilà on a fait un
héros aujourd'hui tout on apprend des
choses aux gens
[Musique]
à moi bah de fil à un ultra ok
maintenant on joue plus qu'elle allumé
et bfm et thanou oued aïssi a pas de
cette vidéo il n'hésitait pas à la
vaisselle vous appelez moi je me suis
bien marré westergaard et vous avez
maintenant comment monter un pc pour
qu'il explose littéralement moment vous
l'allumez donc nous suivent et surtout
pas ce tuto je le répète c'est important
ah oui ya sûrement des mecs ont fait
d'études pour monter son pc de sur
youtube et sont des vrais tuto que vous
pouvez suivre
1 contrairement à celui ci alerté
prochaine de portez vous bien tu as tout
le monde
ouais on finit sur un mec qui se
grattent calmement à la main les amis
[Musique]